it's because you want to get it right
watch my head
I'm always thinking
now I'm looking down so I'm doing the
movements I want to get it right I'm
spending too much time in a cloud you
know of thought you know
I can trick you all by having that same
cloud of the floor
right hey
hey
I can trick you see I look more positive
I got my head off now I'm looking at you
so I'm tricking you really because
inside I'm still going
in oh
it's about all right you know what I
mean we've all been there yeah
but you're showing here to the world
and actually
if you ever need this in a real
situation
you know that way well that's more
likely where they're going to hit you in
an hour and keep you up you know what I
mean what's the problem so don't pick on
me I'm old you know I've got no chance
to get you look how fit you are you're
trying you know yeah
you trying to kill me right I've taught
myself about advice because I've praised
them and I've said you look at me I
don't know each other you know but you
can't do that unless you learn tactics
tactics tactics for the violence
so keep your head up and every one of
them
think
just by
looking
up here and looking doesn't mean it says
something the mechanism is something so
what this is is that human beings trait
it's not a marginal so we don't we're
not born a martial artist
but we can train to be a martial artist
so the difference is one is when you're
headed down this is a this is a human
trade but martial artist trade is
hey
hey hey
yes I'm alive somewhat you know you can
still have the same thoughts
with your head up and with it down I'm
hoping I'm you're making sense to you
that you don't see yourself but you're
actually showing your weakness as a
human being
and we all have that oh
so you overcome it by not showing the
world
we don't really as people we don't
really show the world of who we are
right now you know
they might not like us that's all in our
head